GREG GUTFELD, AND JUAN WILLIAMS.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
HISTORIC DAY IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
LOOKING LIVE AT THE HOUSE FLOOR
AS LAWMAKERS GET READY TO VOTE
ON THE IMPEACHMENT OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
THE DEBATE RAGING FOR HOURS OVER
THE ARTICLES AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT AND IT'S ALL LEADING
TO AN EVENTUAL VOTE LATER
TONIGHT.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI TRYING TO
MAKE THE CASE FOR DEMOCRATS
EARLIER.
>> VERY SADLY NOW, OUR FOUNDER'S
VISION OF A REPUBLIC IS UNDER
THREAT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE PAIR
THAT'S WHY TODAY AS SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE I SOLEMNLY AND SADLY
OPEN A DEBATE ON THE IMPEACHMENT
OF THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
IT'S TRAGIC THE PRESIDENT'S
RECKLESS ACTIONS MAKES
IMPEACHMENT NECESSARY.
HE GAVE US NO CHOICE BE THE
PRESIDENT IS AN ONGOING THREAT
TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS, THE
BASIS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Dana: REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS CALLING
OF THE DEMOCRATS.
>> FROM THE MOMENT THE MAJORITY
PARTY WON THE HOUSE, THE
INEVITABILITY THAT WE WOULD BE
HERE TODAY IS ONLY A MATTER WHAT
DATE THEY WOULD SCHEDULE IT.
NOTHING ELSE.
IN FACT, THEY BEGAN TO EVEN LOOK
FURTHER THAN SEPTEMBER 24, THE
SPEAKER ANNOUNCED IN IMPEACHMENT
HEARING.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT ANYTHING
EXCEPT GETTING THE TIME DONE AND
THE CALENDAR.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT FACTS,
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT TIME.
ONE DAY THE CLOCK IN THE
CALENDAR WILL HANG ALONG THIS
BODY IN A VERY DETRIMENTAL WAY.
>> Dana: ALL HAPPENING WHILE
PRESIDENT TRUMP GEARING FOR A
RALLY TONIGHT IN MICHIGAN.
THE PRESIDENT RIPPING INTO
DEMOCRATS ON TWITTER SAYING,
ATROCIOUS LIES BY THE RADICAL
LEFT DO NOTHING DO-NOTHING
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS AN ASSAULT ON AMERICA
AND AN ASSAULT ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WITH FOUR EXCLAMATION
POINTS.
JESSE, FOUR OF THEM.
THAT IS A LOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING THEY ARE ALL
SAD AND SOLEMN.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT SAD.
THE SQUAD WAS SAYING IMPEACH THE
LETTER MFER AND EVERYBODY WAS CE
LETTER MFER AND EVERYBODY WAS CR
LETTER MFER AND EVERYBODY WAS CN
LETTER MFER AND EVERYBODY WAS C.
THE SADDEST PART IS THEY ARE MAD
BECAUSE THE POLLS TURNED AGAINST
THEM.
WE'LL GET THAT TO A SECOND, ONE
WHEN YOU ARE HANGING A POSTER,
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT SHE HAS TO
SAY.
THE DEMOCRATS TALKING ABOUT THEY
ARE DOING THIS FOR THE FLAG?
THEY BURN FLAGS, THEY KNEEL WHEN
THE FLAG GOES UP AND THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION?
WHEN HAVE WE HEARD ABOUT
DEMOCRATS STRICTLY ADHERING TO
THE CONSTITUTION?
NEVER.
THE WHOLE THING IS FAKE.
WHEN YOU WENT A LONG TIME AGO.
THAT'S WHY THE CNN POLL, THE NPR
POLL, THE IBD, MONMOUTH AND
GALLUP ALL HAVE IMPEACHMENT
UNDERWATER, JUAN.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BASICALLY
DROWNING IN A FLOOD THEY CREATE
CREATED.
>> Dana: CAN I SHOW THE GALLUP
POLL?
THIS HAS THE PRESIDENT OF SIX
POINTS SINCE IMPEACHMENT BEGAN.
JUAN, SINCE JESSE DIRECTED SO
MUCH OF THAT TO YOU, I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO YOU.
>> Juan: THANK YOU.
WHAT YOU SAW THERE IS 45% OF
AMERICA, IT'S ABOUT HALF IN MOST
POLLS INCLUDING THE FOX POLL,
SAYS HE NOT ONLY SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED BUT REMOVED FROM
OFFICE AND WE MOVE TOWARDS
IMPEACHMENT ON THIS HISTORIC DA
DAY.
THE SECOND THING TO SAY AS WELL
AS APPROVAL -- WHAT DID I MISS
MY?
>> Dana: I WAS INTERJECTING
THAT THE NUMBERS FOR THE
PRESIDENT HAVE IMPROVED SINCE
IMPEACHMENT STARTED.
SPEAK TO THE POINT IS THE
COUNTRY IS DIVIDED
>> Juan: THE COUNTRY IS
DIVIDED.
WHEN THIS BEGAN BACK IN
SEPTEMBER IS WHEN WE SAW THE
DEMOCRATS AND MUCH OF THE
COUNTRY SUDDENLY VAULTED TO
CLOSE TO HALF OF THE COUNTRY
SAYING BASED ON WHAT THEY KNOW,
THE EVIDENCE THAT HAD BEEN
PRESENTED TO HIM OF THIS MAN
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
HE HAS ABUSED HIS POWER.
IN TERMS OF HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS
WHICH WERE UP, LIKE, SIX
POINTS -- AGAIN, HE'S IN THE MID
40s.
HE HAS NEVER HAD 50%.
EVEN IN TERMS OF IMPEACHMENT,
REMEMBER, BILL CLINTON WHEN HE
WAS IMPEACHED, HE WAS POPULAR.
HE WAS AT 60% APPROVAL RATING
AND THE DEMAND FOR HIS
IMPEACHMENT WAS, LIKE, AT 29%.
THE CONTRARY WITH DONALD TRUMP
IS HALF THE COUNTRY AND HIS
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE UNDER 50%.
>> Dana: OKAY.
BUT THE NUMBER THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AT NOW IS THE
SAME LEVEL THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD AT THIS POINT IN HIS
REELECTION EFFORTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR FROM AL
GREEN?
>> Greg: I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE REALITY OF THIS.
TRUMP IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
THAT IS WHY PELOSI IS SO SOMBER.
SHE KNOWS SHE HANDED SCHUMER A F
FB OS.
A BIG BAG OF SCHIFF.
DO YOU NOTICE THAT THEY ARE THE
SAME EXACT SOMBER TONE?
THEY ARE ON THE SAME TEAM, BUT
THE MORE SOMBER THEY ARE, THE
BIGGER THE JOKE THEY PLAY ON
THEMSELVES.
I DON'T WANT TO CRITICIZE YOU,
DANA, BUT YOU DIDN'T RIGHT THE
WORD HISTORIC.
BUT WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE IS THAT THIS IS
HISTORIC, RIGHT?
THEY KEEP SAYING, THIS IS
HISTORIC.
THIS IS HISTORIC.
YES, MAYBE IT'S A STORY, BUT NOT
FOR THE REASONS YOU THINK.
IT'S HISTORIC, BECAUSE IT'S THE
FIRST IMPEACHMENT BASED ON
FUTURE ACTIONS.
THEY COULDN'T FIND A CRIME FROM
US AND NOW YOU ARE SAYING THEY
SHOULD GET THEM OUT OF OFFICE IN
CASE TRUMP COMMITS A CRIME.
NOW IT'S "MINORITY REPORT," THE
TOM CRUISE MOVIE.
THIS IS HISTORICAL, THAT'S
AWESOME.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS HAS PULLED
BACK THE CURTAIN.
WE SEE THE MEDIA'S ARROGANCE,
ELITISM, BIAS, ALTOGETHER.
ALL THE LIES THEY PORTRAY AS
FACT.
WHEN TRUMP DIRECTLY DIAGNOSED
FAKE NEWS AS THE ENEMY OF THE
PEOPLE COME EASY UNFOLD.
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING THEM
CRAZY, IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
TRUMP IS GOING TO REMAIN
PRESIDENT, HE'S PROBABLY GOING
TO BE REELECTED USING THE VERY
TOOLS THESE PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY
COULD USE AGAINST THEM.
>> Dana: CONGRESSMAN CHRIS
STEWART, I WILL HAVE YOU REACT
TO THIS.
SPEAKS TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
FUTURE ACTIONS AND WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE IF THIS IS
DONE.
IF YOU COULD PLAY CHRIS STEWART
EARLIER TODAY.
SPEAK IF THE IMPEACHMENT IS
SUCCESSFUL, THE NEXT PRESIDENT I
PROMISE YOU IS GOING TO BE
IMPEACHED.
THE NEXT PRESIDENT AFTER THAT.
IF YOU SET THIS BAR IS BEING
IMPEACHABLE, EVERY PRESIDENT IN
OUR FUTURE WILL BE IMPEACHED.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS RECOGNIZED
THAT THEY GOT IT RIGHT.
HIGH CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS
OTHER THAN THAT SETTLED AT THE
BATTLE BOX.
>> Katie: DEMOCRATS CLAIM THEY
ARE DOING THIS FOR THE COUNTRY,
DOING IT TO PROTECT DEMOCRACY,
AS PELOSI SET UP ALL THE
REPUBLIC, BUT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
THINKING VERY SHORT-TERM.
THE ENTIRE PROCESS HAS SHOWN
THEY ARE COMPLETE HYPOCRITES
THAT CHOSE TO THE LINE FOR THE
NARRATIVE THEY TAKE.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING THE VOTE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS ONLY CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY WHEN THEY WIN BUT WHEN
THERE IS A REPUBLICAN WHO WINS,
THEY PROTEST, THERE ARE LOTS OF
PROTESTERS OUT ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TODAY.
THEY WANTS TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, NOW THEY ARE DOING IT
BUT THIS IS THE FOURTH TIME
THEY'VE TRIED TO DO THIS, LET'S
GO BACK AND REMEMBER WHAT THEY
TRY TO IMPEACH HIM FOR EARLIER.
AL GREEN, FOR EXAMPLE UP OR THEY
TRY TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
CRITICIZING PEOPLE IN THE NFL
FOR KNEELING THE FLAG.
NANCY PELOSI TODAY, SEEMS LIKE
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM IS NOW A
GOOD THING TO BE REVERING AS
SHE'S TRYING TO WIN MAKE THIS
FIGHT.
THEY TRY TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
GOING AFTER THE SQUAD.
TRIED TO IMPEACH HIM FOR SAYING
BAD THINGS ABOUT THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES.
WE'VE BEEN TO THIS BEFORE BUT
THEY LOST OUR GREAT ABILITY
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RUSSIA CASE, PUTTING ALL OF
THEIR STAKE IN ROBERT MUELLER
AND TRY TO PUT ALL OF THIS IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WITH NO CLEAR COMPELLING
EVIDENCE.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THIS AND SAY,
MAY BE CALL WASN'T PERFECT AS
THE PRESIDENT IS ARGUING, BUT WE
SHOULDN'T BE IMPEACHING HIM.
I THOUGHT IT INTERESTING THAT
TULSI GABBARD AS WE LOOK HEAD
HAD MET, SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
VOTING TODAY.
SHE SAID SHE'S GOING TO
INTRODUCE A CENSURE INSTEAD OF
VOTING FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> Dana: WE LOVE AL GREEN.
A CONGRESSMAN WHO'S BEEN CALLING
FOR THE PRESIDENT'S IMPEACHMENT
SINCE THE FIRST DAY.
>> SINCE THE 1950s.
>> Dana: EARLY ON, HE'S BEEN
WANTING THIS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO
SAY TO THEM.
>> IF THIS PRESIDENT IS ALLOWED
TO THWART THE EFFORTS OF
CONGRESS WITH A LEGITIMATE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, THE
PRESIDENT WILL NOT ONLY BE ABOVE
THE LAW, HE WILL BE BEYOND
JUSTICE.
WE CANNOT ALLOW ANY PERSON TO BE
BEYOND JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN THE NAME OF DEMOCRACY, ON
BEHALF OF THE REPUBLIC, AND FOR
THE SAKE OF THE MANY WHO ARE
SUFFERING, I WILL VOTE TO
IMPEACH, AND I ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO SO AS WELL.
>> Greg: IF HE HAD A
LEGITIMATE CASE, WHY WOULD HE
HAVE TO SHOW UP WITH A GIANT
PHOTO OF A LITTLE GIRL NOT PART
OF IMPEACHMENT AND A DEBUNKED
STORY ABOUT SEPARATION?
IF HE WAS PURELY CONFIDENT HE
HAD A CASE, HE WOULDN'T NEED TO
LIE ABOUT AMERICA WHICH HE HAS
BEEN FOR QUITE A WHILE.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE REDS GOT
THE BEST OF THE DEMOCRATS.
IF WE REMEMBER, THERE WERE
DEMOCRATS WHO REFUSED TO CERTIFY
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
THERE WERE DEMOCRATS WHO
BOYCOTTED THE INAUGURATION.
THE CAMPAIGN OF THE PRESIDENT
WAS SPIED ON, THEY HATCHED A
PARTISAN WITCH HUNTS, ACCUSE HIM
BEING A TRAITOR TO THE COUNTRY,
OF WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THAT WAS ALL A HOAX.
THE DAY THE HOAX EVAPORATED WITH
MUELLER'S TESTIMONY, THEY
CONCOCTED THIS OTHER FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER STORY, AND JUAN
SAID SOMETHING VERY INTERESTING
ABOUT THE POLLS WHERE THEY WERE
WHEN THIS WHOLE THING STARTED IN
SEPTEMBER.
I AGREE, THE POLLS WERE AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT THEN.
BUT AS MORE PEOPLE READ THE
TRANSCRIPT AND AS MORE PEOPLE
HEARD WHAT THE DEMOCRATS' CASE
WAS, THOSE POLLS TURN RIGHT
UPSIDE DOWN.
SPEED TO GET OUT...
THE POLLS REMAIN STAGNANT ON
THIS POINT.
>> Jesse: YOU'VE BEEN
SAYING --
YOU DON'T TELL THE AUDIENCE
ABOUT THE TREND.
>> Juan: WHAT TREND?
>> Jesse: I'M NOT GOING TO
ARGUE WITH YOU.
THE AUDIENCE KNOWS I'M RIGHT.
>> Juan: YOU ARE RIDICULOUSLY
WRONG.
WHAT YOU HEAR FROM MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IS A REQUEST FOR YOU, THE
AUDIENCE, TO ONE, NOT TREATED AS
A HISTORIC THING EVEN THOUGH
IT'S JUST THE THIRD U.S.
PRESIDENT WHO IS GOING TO BE
IMPEACHED.
SECONDLY, IGNORE IT.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS, OH, THEY ARE
SO WRONG.
>> Jesse: WE'VE COVERED THIS
EVERY HOUR OF THE DAY!
>> Juan: IT'S THE MEDIA,
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Juan:
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRATS --
DONALD TRUMP MADE A PHONE CALL!
>> Juan: YES, AND DEMOCRAT DEL
McDONALD TRUMP MADE A PHONE
CALL ABOUT HIS POLITICAL
INTEREST.
YOU KNOW, THE FAMOUS LINE, WHEN
SCHEDULES CALL UP THE
PATRIOTISM, IS TO DISGUISE
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
DIVIDE ATTENTION.
THE CLEAR CASE OF ABUSE OF POWER
BY THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: THE ONLY ABUSE OF
POWER IS THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Jesse: WHEN TRUMP WINS
REELECTION, HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
MANDATE LIKE YOU'VE NEVER SEEN.
>> Juan: IF YOU CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY --
>> Greg: THEY'VE BACKED
THEMSELVES INTO A CORNER.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTION THAT SAYS THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW,
HE IS ONE OF US.
>> Dana: I DO WANT TO MAKE A
POINT ABOUT THE FAIRNESS
ARGUMENT.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN TO
SOUND BITE NUMBER FOUR, UP IN
THE CONTROL ROOM.
KATIE, I THINK THIS IS THE OTHER
THING IS PEOPLE WATCHED ALL OF
THIS.
THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS HAS COME
UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR YEARS
DOUG COLLINS EARLIER TODAY.
>> THE MINORITY LEADER IN THE
SENATE WENT OUT AND DID A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND SAY, THEY DENIED
MY WITNESSES!
THEY WERE DENIED BY REQUEST!
WELCOME TO THE CLUB,
MR. SCHUMER.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
OVER HERE FOR THE LAST THREE
MONTHS.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE
DECISION TO NOT ALLOW WITNESSES
FROM THE REPUBLICANS AND NOW
HAVING TO PAY A PRICE FOR IT?
>> Katie: THEY'VE GIVEN
CHUCK SCHUMER NOWHERE TO GO AND
THEY MADE HIM DOMINATE HIS
DEMANDS LOOK REALLY SILLY WHEN
ADAM SCHIFF GAVE NO WIGGLE ROOM
TO REPUBLICANS, DAMAGING THEIR
CREDIBILITY ON THE ISSUE.
I THINK WHEN THE PRESIDENT TALKS
ABOUT DUE PROCESS AND FAIRNESS
AND REPUBLICANS TALK ABOUT IT,
EVERYDAY AMERICANS CAN RELATE
DIRECTLY TO THAT.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO BE FALSELY
ACCUSED OF A CRIME OR DOING
SOMETHING THEY DID NOT DO OR
BEING REMOVED FROM THE POSITION
CIVIL BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
THEM OR HAVE OF THIS AGREEMENT
THEIR POLICIES.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SEVERELY UNDERESTIMATING THE
BLOWBACK OF THEIR NEXT YEAR.
IF DEMOCRATS REALLY HAD A SOLID
ARGUMENT ON THIS, THERE WOULDN'T
BE DEMOCRATS CHANGING THEIR
PARTY TO REPUBLICANS, AND THERE
WOULDN'T BE MORE DEFECTIONS
TODAY AFTER ALL THE EVIDENCE
THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED FOR
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE.
>> Dana: DID YOU GUYS SEE
THIS?
I DO NOT KNOW HOW REAL IT IS BUT
IT'S REAL ENOUGH TO MAKE A LOT
OF HEADLINES A COUPLE OF HOURS
AGO, THERE IS A MOVEMENT AMONG
SOME ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE TO
HAVE NANCY PELOSI NOT SEND THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT TO THE
SENATE, DENYING THE PRESIDENT A
TRIAL, AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ACQUITTED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> Greg: HERE IS THE THING
FROM WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS
THEY'VE BELITTLED THE ACTUAL
IMPORTANCE OF IMPEACHMENT,
RIGHT?
ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
BY THE WAY, EVERYBODY GETS THEIR
TURN AT BAT, SO IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WHAT TRUMP HAS DONE WITH
IMPEACHMENT IS TO HIS ADVANTAGE.
WHAT SEEMS TO BE AN INJURY
ACTUALLY TURNS INTO A PASSAGE OF
HONOR.
IT'S LIKE, THIS WILL HELP
GALVANIZE HIS BASE PAY PROBABLY
GOING TO WIN REELECTION BECAUSE
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEA,
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEAN
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEAT
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEAO
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEAM
IT IS SUCH A FRAUD BECAUSE, YEAI
GOING TO BE IMPEACHED, BUT I'M
GOING TO BE THE FIRST
REELECTED -- I'M GOING TO BE
REELECTED AFTER IMPEACHMENT?
>> Greg: THAT'LL BE HISTORIC.
>> Juan: THAT WOULD BE A SAD,
SAD THING.
>> Greg: I KNOW YOU'LL AGREE
WITH ME.
D.C. STYLE IS IN NEED OF
IMPROVEMENT.
HERE'S THE OTHER COMEDY PART OF
IT.
THE 2010S ARE THE GREATEST
DECADE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
WE ARE SEEING THE GREATEST
ECONOMY IN HISTORY, PROBABLY THE
BEST YEAR, 2019, IN OUR ECONOMIC
MODERN HISTORY.
THE CUSTODIAN OF THAT ECONOMY IN
A TIME WHERE WE ARE SEEING
REDUCTIONS TO DISEASE, INCREASE
IN INCOME, IS BEING IMPEACHED.
THE BEST YEAR, THE BEST ECONOMY,
THE BEST DECADE OF THE WORLD,
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GET THE
CUSTODIAN OUT OF THE JOB.
>> Juan: EVERY DECADE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED HAS BEEN BETTER THAN
THE LAST, GREG.
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY HALLMARK.
>> Greg: WAY BETTER, JUAN.
>> Juan: I THINK AS A HUMAN
RACE HAVE MAJOR MEN'S PROGRESS.
TO SUGGEST THAT, DONALD TRUMP
SHOWED UP AND THE BILLIONAIRE
MADE IT ALL RIGHT.
>> Greg: WHY IS IT ABOUT
MONEY?
>> Juan: THEY IGNORE WHAT
OBAMA DID IN TERMS OF SETTING
THIS UP.
>> Greg: YOU THINK IT'S
OBAMA...
SPEED TO LET IT GO.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT DEMOCRATS,
THERE IS A DEMOCRAT WHO HAS GONE
TO TANZANIA TO AVOID THIS VOTE.
THE PROBLEM IS REPUBLICAN
BLINDNESS TO FACTS.
>> Greg: WHERE ARE THE FACTS?
YOU ARE DOING IMPEACHMENT TO
PREVENT THE FUTURE.
>> Juan: MAYBE IT'S THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN TRANSCRIPT OF
HIS OWN PHONE CALL.
>> Greg: WHICH WAS ACTUALLY A
PERFECT PHONE CALL.
>> Dana: THIS IS ADAM SCHIFF
AND GOING BACK THAT THEY ARE
IMPEACHING THEM FOR FUTURE
ACTIONS BECAUSE THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT BETWEEN 20 ELECTION.
SOUND BITE 12.
>> THE TIMELINE IS DRIVEN MORE
BY THE FACT THAT THE PLOT
CONTINUES BY THE PRESIDENT
SEEKING STILL TO ESSENTIALLY
CHEAT IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
THAT IS NOT A REMEDY OR HIS
MISCONDUCT.
THE REMEDY IS IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S WHY WE MOVE FORWARD AND
WE'VE DONE SO METHODICALLY BUT
NONETHELESS WITH A SENSE OF
URGENCY.
>> Dana: JESSE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
HE SAID THE PRESIDENT IS SEEKING
STILL TO ESSENTIALLY CHEAT IN
THE NEXT ELECTION.
>> Jesse: THAT'S A LIE, LIKE
THEY ARE LYING ABOUT TRUMP
CHEATING IN THE LAST ELECTION.
PEOPLE LIE BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
ACCEPT THE TRUTH AND THE TRUTH
IS DEMOCRATS LOST IN 2016 AND
THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE AGAIN IN
2020.
THEY ARE PROTECTING THEIR OWN
BASE FROM GOING CRAZY BECAUSE I
NEED TO SEND A POISON TO KEEP IT
CALM BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
CRAZY AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE GOT
IMPEACHMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE
BUT NONE OF THESE CLOWNS CAN
BEAT THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
PREIMPEACH HIM.
THIS IS JUST A SHORT CIRCUIT OF
DEMOCRACY.
AND TO SAY DONALD TRUMP GETS
CREDIT FOR BARACK OBAMA'S
ECONOMY IS NONSENSE.
>> Juan: OKAY.
>> Jesse: WHICH ECONOMY IS IT?
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO WHEN
THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
RECESSION, TRUMP WAS BLAMED.
STOCKMARKET RECORDS ARE BEING
SMASHED AND IT'S OBAMA'S?
>> Juan: HANG ON, LET'S GO TO
THE FACTS FOR A MINUTE AND STOP
WITH THE RHETORIC.
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS, JESSE.
>> Greg: THAT'S RHETORIC.
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS?
>> Juan: RUDY GIULIANI
CONTINUES TO TRAVEL TO THE
UKRAINE, TRYING TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION ON THE PRESIDENT'S
LIKELY OPPONENT JOE BIDEN AND
YOU SAY, NO, THERE IS NO THREAT
TO THE PRESIDENT CHEATING AGAIN.
JESSE COLIN BIDEN CAN DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS OVERSEAS?
SPEED TO GET OUT OVER HERE.
JOE BIDEN HAS HIS LAWYERS.
>> Juan: THIS IS REPUBLICAN
BLIND THAN THE
BLINDNESS.
>> Dana: KATIE, GO FOR IT.
>> Katie: LET'S FOCUS ON
FACTS.
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR FOREIGN
INVOLVEMENT BY PAYING A
COMPANY -- A FIRM THAT WAS USING
A FOREIGN SPY TO GET INFORMATION
FROM RUSSIAN SOURCES TO BE USED
BY THE FBI TO GO AFTER
PRESIDENTS OR CANDIDATES.
IF SHE WERE TO WIN, IF YOU
DIDN'T, SHE WOULD'VE BEEN
IMPEACHED OVER THAT BECAUSE THAT
IS FAR WORSE THAN ANYTHING THE
PRESIDENT SAID IN HIS PHONE
CALL.
BACK TO ADAM SCHIFF REALLY
QUICKLY, THAT'S WHAT HE SAID IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF CLAIMING TO
PROTECT DEMOCRACY WHILE
COMPLETELY UNDERMINING IT AND
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT FALSELY
OF THINGS THAT HE DID NOT DO.
YOU HAVE JERRY NADLER SAYING, WE
CAN'T TRUST THE NEXT ELECTION TO
FIX THE PROBLEM.
IF THIS IS HAPPENING IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY, IN A DEMOCRACY,
THE STATE WOULD BE COMING TO
COMBINATION OF THE OPPOSING